What could be the problem if I'm having headaches after I eat?
Well headaches
After you eat would be a lot of things. I mean anytime you have a headache the first thing you think of is inflammation. So
You could have a muscular inflammation can be causing a headache so there can be a muscular headaches
There can be intracranial inflammation that can be causing a headache
You can have cervical neck subluxations that can be causing a headache
So there's a lot of causes for headaches. What do you think? Oh, it's oh, I don't know. Is it only after you eat?
I mean if there's only after you eat you could think of anything that's causing inflammation in your gut
That's causing inflammation in the brain. So like I said
inflammation in the gut is going to cause inflammation in the brain
Well, what and what so if there anything you're eating that's causing inflammation in the gut
And it doesn't have to be a food sensitivity quote of quote
It's something that's irritating the gut that's causing inflammation. That's what I would think
Um, that's a first thing I would think it was try to narrow down
What it is that you're eating that is doing that
Um, now if it's anything you eat it's good to say anything I
causes this
Then I would say we just have general inflammation in the gut and I would go take a step back and start doing some gut healing
protocol
That's what sunspectrum and the SBI protect can be very beneficial for that